Shh hold the smallest and clearly the
cutest fox on earth weighing in at just
two pounds it's a native of the deserts
of northern Africa and actually those
ears are a big help in a heat they act
kind of like radiators when air hits the
ears it cools down the blood inside then
the chilled blood circulates through the
whole body
elephants do the same thing when you see
one flapping its ears it's probably
trying to cool off or take flight like
Dumbo the fox's ears also make it a
formidable nocturnal hunter it's keen
sense of hearing lets it locate insects
and reptiles in the darkness and weirdly
for a mammal it's got fur on the bottom
of its paws that keeps the fox's feet
from baking on the desert sand and gives
the Fox better grip but for now it's
time for a snooze
you